hi hey hi I'm so sorry I'm late so for
my birthday we're going up north for a
week you're gonna come right yeah it's
gonna be fine
yeah it just came up just kidding
it came up remember this thing I talked
about that sales thing turns out now
they do need me to go why
just I came up I guess what am I gonna
do without you my beautiful cow
we are so glad that you came happy
birthday happy birthday to you
we just really want you to relax relax
in what way
my beautiful cow
hey baby is everything okay
going on
so I think I'm gonna have to leave early
when did he become more important to you
than us
oh yes Berlin I lied to him he has every
right to be angry lied about why about
being here
good girl
I didn't know you were coming well I'm
sure Alice will explain it all later
are you sorry for what you did how are
we supposed to be happy together if we
can't trust each other
how did Simon know you were here looked
at my email I heard about the girl who
went missing pretty worried about me
my beautiful girl
since we think love is I don't know how
any of this is your business Simon loves
me I'm happy
[Music]
why did you lie to him I can't do
another thing wrong
my beautiful girl
the only person who knows you
oh nice Alice darling
nobody loves you like I love you
my beautiful cow